esta vez vamos a trabajar con los
porcentajes y veamos si podemos
descubrir cuánto
30% de
y esto está muy sencillo lo vamos a
poder analizar de dos maneras uno es
pensar en 30 % 30 de cada 100 recuerda
que este por ciento nos indica que es de
cada cien así es que si tengo treinta
de cada 100 lo multiplicar por 6 o la
otra manera que se me ocurre es pensar
en
30 centésimos como lo pueden ver aquí 30
sobre 100 es igual a 30
centésimos por 6
primero vamos a hacer este de arriba y
veremos que es muy sencillo 30 sobre 100
por 6 sobre 1 realmente este 6 está
sobre 1 será igual a 30 por 6 180
y los denominadores también los
multiplicaremos 100 por 1 100 la
multiplicación de numeradores fue 30 por
6 180 y la multiplicación de
denominadores fue 100 por 1 100 si
nosotros buscamos la fracción
simplificada de esta fracción tendremos
lo siguiente ambos números tienen como
factor común 10 así es que si dividimos
entre 10 tendremos 18 décimos pero
también el 18 décimos tiene factores
comunes que en este caso sería 2 si
divido 18 entre 2 será igual a 9
es entre dos será igual a cinco y de
esta manera tenemos nueve quintos como
fracción simplificada vamos a verlo como
números mixtos donde tenemos enteros el
9 es más grande que el 5 y el 5 cabe una
vez un entero y nos quedarán cuatro
quintos
cómo puedo tener esto en números
decimales pues muy sencillo tengo un
entero y para saber cuál será el número
decimal dividiremos cuatro quintos que
es igual a punto 8 de cualquier manera
vamos a hacer la división tendremos 4
entre 5 y aquí podemos ver que bueno el
5 no caben 4 agregaremos decimales de
precisión y tendremos
0 por 5 040 es igual a 4 bajo el primer
cero de los decimales 40 entre 5 es
igual a 8
recuerden tener mucha precaución de
siempre poner el punto decimal
exactamente arriba en la misma posición
donde se encuentran 8 x 5 40 40 menos 40
será igual a cero tenemos residuos cero
por lo que cuatro quintos es igual a
punto 88 decimos y de esta manera
llegamos a que el 30 por ciento de 61.8
vamos a corroborar esto de este lado
tengo 30 centésimos o tres décimos
realmente por 6 vamos a hacer la
multiplicación
decimos
por 6
6 x 3
18 600 y únicamente tenemos un valor
posicional recorrido hacia la izquierda
el punto se dan cuenta tenemos un solo
valor posicional recorrido así es que
nosotros también recorreremos en la
respuesta un solo valor posicional
y tenemos 1.8
y así de sencillo por dos mecanismos
hemos comprobado
el 30 por ciento de 6 es igual a 1.8